- [Voiceover] There were
10 sharks at the reef.
And we see, there's one,
two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, 10
sharks, just like they told us.
Two sharks swam away, I
was gonna say ran away,
(laughs), they swam away.
How many sharks are left?
So, let's think about it.
There were 10 sharks at the reef
and two of them, two of them, swam away,
so how many sharks are left?
How many sharks are left?
Well, what's 10 minus
two going to be equal to?
Well, we could look up
here if we had 10 pictures
of sharks and we were to take away,
we were to take away one and then two,
how many are going to be left?
Well, we see we have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, and eight.
So, 10 minus two, 10
taking away two sharks,
the two sharks that swam away,
is going to be equal to eight.